good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend friday friday getting
down on friday
today is actually
friday because thrace is in the building
hello theodore my love my angel my
nephew my perfect love it's friday but
it's also
try day
because today we are putting our money
oh we're putting our mouths
our money where our mouths are we're
really today we're putting our mouths
where our money is right so yesterday we
mostly me we're just like annihilating
the internet for this dumb balsamic
vinegar trend and
it's really kind of unfair and not cool
of me to speak on a trend i haven't
participated in so through no choice of
my own i was forced by you yeah i think
it's important you want to talk about
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] around and find out [ __ ]
around and find out so we're just going
to kick off today's show
um testing out this new healthy coke
trend which consists of balsamic vinegar
over ice with lacroix
so i have all my ingredients i cannot
you know i've never
tasted balsamic vinegar in my life like
the smell makes me
oh but let me smell it it's like really
rich wait let me just pour and then you
can so it's just a little bit no it's
more than that i watched a video no it's
like that okay a little bit more no it's
like that smell it it's really rich it's
a smell it's really rich this is a
expensive bottle i think
oh yeah that's
fragrant then we're going to take our
sparkling lacroix this is the lime
flavor which i think makes sense you
know diet coke with lime love it and
apparently you just pour it over in our
morning toast tumbler available at
shopmorningtoast.com even though i think
it might be sold out
we have tumblers for sure though and
then
and you're going to i know you're trying
to outweigh the balsamic no no no no i
mean i can see i'm telling you this is
what i can see that you're trying to no
look
maybe i do need a little bit more
a little bit more yeah
you wouldn't drink a diet coke that
looks like that's so twisted
over my white pants that's what you get
for being a tick tocker
okay
okay that looks like a diet coke that
had the ice melt in it sure
oh
i mean it smells like balsamic
vinaigrette but it smells like balsamic
vinaigrette mixed with a coke it really
does
i'm just going to smell it really mixed
[Music]
there is something coke-like yeah but
there's also something balsamic yes
okay
you guys don't understand like what a
big deal it is i'm not trying to be
annoying and like stall but you don't
want to understand what a big deal it is
for me i've never had balsamic vinegar
in my life like i think it is the most
disgusting sauce or whatever you want to
call it on the planet like when people
dip it into their breads like i
immediately think they're disgusting and
i won't like go near them because
they're breast smells wow i like to dip
my bread in oil and i know
so does ben
okay are you filming this for your tick
tock i mean i'm gonna clip it for two
times okay so make sure to be like
like i really can't you have to because
you brought it up and you can't speak on
things which you don't know about you
don't understand like how stubborn i am
like i don't eat things that i don't
like to eat you know what i mean that's
how i've literally never had balsamic
vinegar in my life yeah just do it it's
like ripping off a band-aid it's like
ripping off a band-aid it'll be over it
would have been over if you took that
for sure but i just just to so people
think i'm not being dramatic
this is the equivalent of me drinking
this is like a normal human being with
like a normal taste palette mixing up
duty and literally drinking it through a
straw so i just want to let you know
this is what i do for likes and views
subscribe
okay
oh my god oh my god oh my god seriously
take it like i'm really gonna throw up
oh my god oh my god why do we do that
drink you drink it [ __ ] you
oh my god i need something stronger
oh
drink it
drink it drink it you drink it drink it
how did this become about me our show
come on you drink it how did this become
about me
oh my god i'm not gonna be able to
breathe through my nose for the rest of
the show like go eat a snack you on
goldfish no no i want you to drink it
you're not getting out of this
you guys just [ __ ] sick
oh i can't breathe
what do you think like
it's
it's not that it's obviously like not
coke but like if someone served that to
you to me not to you because clearly you
can't handle but if someone served
that's me at a restaurant i'd be like ew
this restaurant has disgusting diet coke
no that cannot be mistaken for diet coke
no like it could be it has the
consistency
it could be i could see why a pilates
instructor would think so you guys i'm
literally never going to be the same
like dead you need to cleanse your
palate you needed a moose boosh i need a
doda grab some goldfish for her
oh my god you need to lose your bush
girl and if i'm like burping it up like
this is really one of the worst things
you guys have ever made me do throw i'll
i need to use something
that's the price of being on tick tock
so true honestly it's too expensive do
you know what i did last night what
downloaded tiktok nope close i stalked
your tick tock on zach's phone and the
people like really love us honestly the
people really love you yeah they were
saying well of course i looked at the
videos where it's like i'm shining
um and they were saying such nice things
about your girl
you know last time i was on tick tock
and like if i ever dared to post
something like without makeup they said
i looked like a boy
that was mean
they said who's this boy that is mean i
said that's a girl okay i feel better
you just need to lose your boost like
thank you for making me do that do that
like i said the content your tick tock
is probably gonna blow up i'm disgusted
but what if you got 5 000 followers from
this would it be worth it yeah
everyone get to get to tap in yeah for
sure um so thank you for making me do
that now we can finally move on today's
show like literally when you guys came
up with the idea yesterday like i
haven't thought of anything about like
like really you came up with the idea
you're the one who chose that story it
wasn't my idea to try it no but like
you were not if you never brought it up
you wouldn't be trying it and if i never
brought it up we wouldn't be the
relevant iconic show that we are that's
also true so we do what we have to do to
be like
who we are which is everything of the
sort facts she's speaking facts today
you guys for friday friday we have a
great show we've got five stories that
are bleak they're depressing honestly um
and then we have the kardashians recap
new episode of the kardashians on hulu
um the tristan of it all so we'll get
into that anything else you want to
catch up on it's also friday so i would
be remiss i would be devastated and i
would be heartbroken
if it didn't if i didn't remind you guys
that today's friday it is the furthest
away from the weekend we are ever going
to be nope that's not true furthest away
from monday we are ever going to be
that's true i want you to acknowledge
the space that you're in close your eyes
for a moment just acknowledge it realize
how blessed we are it could be a tuesday
but it's not it's a friday we've got
saturday and sunday coming up and it's
not over yet you know it's just
beginning it's all it's all on the
horizon it's all exciting
think about that
take a second
matter of fact
that was so peaceful namaste
i really think we should do manifest not
manifestations meditations okay where we
have everyone acknowledge the space that
we're in and we just talk about the days
of the week 100 we should start like a
whole other podcast every day it's like
a five minute meditation about what day
it is and how you're going to get
through it and it's called
friday sure
friday friday um
yeah okay i'm ready yeah because i like
meditating is really i was just
meditating and i really was present yeah
in your guided thing meditation and i
feel so relaxed like not too should i
meditate for you well i was gonna say
not to insult the meditation community
like i think it's a hoax okay and i mean
maybe just for me like i'm incapable of
meditating okay can you yeah yeah i know
we made you drink balsamic vinegar i
don't know if we can restore your piece
but it really likes okay and do your
hands like this how i did something
about it's peaceful no there's nothing
peaceful about using my muscles to hold
my arms up like if i want to be at peace
like my limbs are totally relaxed
like even i need to uncross my legs like
gonna say any sort of strain on my body
will not relax me okay close your eyes
picture this
it's friday
you're getting into bed you go to your
phone should i set my alarm
no
we are ushering in some alarm free
living how long will i sleep it's
anybody's guess i've seen god's hands
now
that's you're not part of meditation
i've got theo beside me he's freshly
groomed he said mommy i'm tired can we
sleep 12 hours
you say of course theo because it's
friday
namaste that didn't sound like
meditation it sounds like you were
reading me a children's book and like
that was the end of it like it's friday
that's a really good way for a book to
end yeah we should also while we're
doing new business ventures mogul energy
we should also write a children's book
about days of the week we'll release
seven of them
and you know it'll be a cash grab
because you have to buy every single
book in order for like the kids to learn
the days of the week right and we teach
them at a young age which days to
appreciate and which days to put a brave
face on for yeah which days to just
like truck through you know
keep your head down it'll be over soon
it'll be over soon just like get through
it yeah i love that let's put that on
our list of mogul aspirations and of
course the children's book where it's
bruno theo butterson mystery taking on
the town right right right taking
people were really kind of swept up in
our dog group drama yesterday i have to
be honest when we were telling the story
i felt like it was something that i like
i find so much personal joy in thinking
about the dynamics of the dog walk and
we go back and forth like larping and
coming up with scenarios of what these
dogs are thinking and going through and
i really didn't think it was going to
resonate so deeply with everyone and i'm
so i feel so seen that it has you know
me too truly and i can't wait to see
butters later today i know did i see
butters yesterday i saw him yesterday no
i was i was out of pocket but
mystery remains a mystery and that's
that's on being mysterious you love that
for her
namesake unclear gender
wise
uh so i guess without further ado we can
get into the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
because the sooner we do the sooner it's
the weekend it's so true for us you know
for them too because then this hour has
passed right right right in your one
hour closer to alarm free living today's
episode is brought to you by solo stove
upgrade your backyard with a solo stove
fire pit and create story worthy moments
without the fireside fumes so solo stove
is a stainless steel construction
designed to regulate airflow and burn
more efficiently there's so little smoke
you'll wonder how there's so much fire
it's the perfect catalyst for getting
outside and spending more time with
family and friends you can build lasting
memories around a solo stove fire pit so
if your backyard or
house doesn't have a fire pit that can
be really like outrageously expensive um
a solo stuff is great because you just
unbox it and you can start using it
immediately it's portable so if you're
going camping you're going on a trip
you're renting a house with friends you
can bring it with you just throw it in
the trunk and the way that it's designed
is really designed to eliminate smoke
because the worst part of like sitting
around a nice fire is like when you're
in the seat that just gets all the smoke
it is so effing annoying
so solo stove fire pits are built
engineered built and engineered to be
used
easily and they're built to last they're
easy to use with a few bits of starter
your fire will be blazing in minutes and
they're so confident that you'll love it
they offer a lifetime warranty and a 30
day free return policy right now you can
get big discounts on all fire pits
during solo stove's summer sale use
promo code toast at solostove.com for an
extra 10 off that's solo stove s-o-l-o
stove dot com promo code toast for ten
dollars off on top of their incredible
summer sale discounts but hurry their
summer sale ends june 23rd don't miss
out
great okay our first story britney's
wedding evening lots to discuss a lot of
pictures have emerged thankfully as we
said yesterday we were looking forward
to seeing them and as predicted by us
there was no major exclusive it was like
all just on bernie's instagram yeah but
like where are all these pictures from
there are some like the daily mail has
90 pictures that are like the
photographer pictures yeah i guess like
and there's no exclusive right
everyone's posting them it was probably
just pr like releasing them like
yeah no very very grateful because it
was star studded it was so britney wowed
in a versace gown as she tied the knot
for the third time with sam ashgari in a
fairy tale ceremony before dancing the
night away with a-list guests including
drew barrymore selena gomez madonna
paris hilton ansel elgort until elgort
was there but also it was a small
wedding there was like 50 people and
those are her close personal friends the
selena gomez one was the real shock to
me yeah ansel elgort was shocking too
um yeah drew barrymore wasn't shocking
they've had like a public like
friendship budding over the last couple
years because i think drew feels like
very connected to brittany in the sense
like child stars perhaps exploited by
their parents like they have this
kinship and actually really really liked
your barry moore so i was happy she was
there um madonna obviously and brittany
go back to making out on the vmas um
selena gomez was unique for sure yeah
but she was dancing the night away there
was a lot of action shots from the party
yeah and you know what i really liked
about selena first of all she looks like
she was having so much fun like in the
picture she's like sweaty and she's like
dancing kind of like crazy like she
doesn't care she looks like she's having
so much fun which we love yeah and she
wore a jumpsuit which like to be able to
pull off a jumpsuit to a wedding is so
difficult well it's a thursday night
affair so jumpsuit is in play yeah and
she looked really great and also you
were so right the wedding was giving
chugalicious but that's why we that's
why we stand like that's why we should
know but it was like absolutely gorgeous
like look at this photo quickly from the
daily mail like that's
like a horse and carriage it was very it
was a very very disney wedding yeah and
she wore a versace gown not a crop top
thigh-high slit
some of this stuff is like confusing
like did you see this picture of her
no in like her foyer and there's a broom
in the back yeah no that's britney like
if it's not happening in her foyer she's
not going to participate that's true but
perform no her foyer is so
honestly should be made a landmark like
her foyer has witnessed so many iconic
dance videos so the fact that like the
first wedding photo we saw was in that
exact foyer it feels right yeah that's
true
there was also a lot of breaking news
coming out of the way her first husband
or second husband jason alexander who
were they were married for five seconds
literally it was less than a day crashed
the wedding he was arrested okay i have
two things to say about that first of
all like the fact that george costanza
didn't crash a wedding was beyond
confusing to me i will never get over
the fact that brittany married someone
with the same name as the man who plays
george costanza and like you're never
going to say jason alexander and i'm not
going to think of george costanza right
so i'm always like jared i'm like jason
george costanzo was at the wedding and
then it takes a second for me to you
know adjust to reality and the second
thing is he was crashing the wedding
like literally breaking into her house
all on instagram live and like for
someone the level of fame that britney
is like the way that her
security guards literally followed him
around like letting him instagram like
the wedding he went inside the tent he
was in her house like uh tackle this man
he's literally trespassing that's so
crazy it was so weird like the relaxed
level of the security and what were his
intentions to stop the weapon i wanted
to see brittany to get her back i don't
know he wanted to see britain he was
like in the house screaming brittany
where are you
that's crazy
unwell also her sons were not at the
wedding right which is so sad because
then that means like literally no family
was at the wedding except for i think
her brother who i'm not even familiar
with i wonder why her sons weren't there
and also they're like grown now they're
15 and 16. like they're making their own
decisions yeah if they really had wanted
to be there i don't think that their dad
could have stopped
them
yeah
but it was kevin's attorney who said
that they're not going to be at the
wedding kevin fetterline yeah
they think the focus of the day should
be on brittany and sam and they're very
happy for her moving forward says that's
where me if they were happy they would
be there it's a simcha there's something
weird i just like i feel and i really
love things weird i would say so there's
two things i want to say the first is
that i really have this feeling and i
hope that it's true that like kevin
federline is an amazing dad like i
really kind of feel that way and i hope
that he is
the second thing i want to say is that
while i think this is great
i think
i don't
i think this is a simcha for sure and
there's so much to celebrate in the last
year for brittany
um
but i feel like there's
kind of like something we're all like
thinking
but like not saying and it's like is
britney really truly okay yeah just and
you know you really do never know what's
going on with someone like behind closed
doors but the the things we see it's all
very confusing yeah so i just i hope
that she's okay honestly like i don't
know what her current like status is but
i just
i just would wanted to say that yeah i
think there's concern from everyone i
mean i think people can be like really
weird on social media but also be
agreeing um but there's a lot of
question marks and flags that look a
shade of red right but we just kind of
move past it because we're so happy for
brittany right this new era of her life
which i agree with but i just really do
want to make i really hope there are
people around her
who actually care for her
because i think she got to a place where
everyone around her was an enemy so she
literally got rid of everyone i'm under
the guise of caring for her so now it's
like she wants freedom and that also
includes like not having people
overseeing i'm sure she's trepidatious
of people who claim to care about her
right because it's backfired so i don't
know i just like the whole thing kind of
gives me like a little bit of a pit yeah
for sure especially hearing that the
kids weren't there i know oh so people
were saying yesterday that kevin
federline is like
a couch potato and
just like living off
the land okay and yes not rocking the
boat because he's in a pretty nice boat
but if he's living off the land but like
taking really good care of the kids like
i'm okay with that yeah this is a unique
usually like men who leech off of
successful women like literally i want
to run you over with my car i think
there's nothing more disgusting um but
in this scenario i'm issuing um
an exemption yeah especially if he has
majority custody he's raising the kids
that takes some funds i agree and i
think it's okay
assuming that's the situation but again
there's a lot here that remains unclear
it's a lot to unpack but at the end of
the day she looked really pretty and the
wedding was pretty it was started it
wasn't thrown together it was really
like quite gorgeous yeah and
very lovely
really like textbook fairy tale wedding
you know yeah and that's so britney's
aesthetic so she's you know what i love
when you go to a wedding you could see
like the bride came through in like her
vibe her interests her choices her it
likes and that's like this britney if
you showed me this wedding and was like
which celebrity wedding is this i'm like
it's obviously britney's divide came
through for sure yeah
and nice of her celeb friends to show up
yeah
and it looked like they had a nice time
yeah
are you ready for our next story
yeah
crystal kong minkoff suggests that
sutton told a different problematic
story it's the tale that never ends no
it's literally like the crystal who
cried wolf uh-huh i'm still so inclined
not to believe her crystal who called
problematic yeah
crystal insinuated that sutton told an
even darker story than the one revealed
on wednesday's episode of beverly hills
crystal appeared on watch what happens
live on wednesday and surprisingly
agreed with fans who said that sudden
story about her daughter having
multicultural friends at a pool party
wasn't an issue but why at the dinner
did she literally ask herself don't you
think that's problematic
because this woman is she's getting
caught in her life yeah she said
something else was here she goes again
well that story wasn't problematic she
said to andy who paused and said there's
another story the housewife appeared to
have something on the tip of her tongue
but decided not to divulge the details
so you're telling me crystal's getting
dragged like literally i've never seen a
housewife in beverly hills get dragged
like so ruthlessly on social media she's
getting dragged to no extent
and she still has something she could
technically come out with like the truth
but she's not doing it to protect sutton
who literally just blew up at her it's
so it's so unbelievable they're like
coming at her with you know concern
about like what she said in her behavior
and she's going back to her original
retort which is like garcelle you know
questioned what she did so she was like
no satan said something bad now fast
forward to however many months they're
coming for her for what she's doing no
sutton said something bad it's like did
not learn the first time either say it
as we've stated say it or don't mention
it no and you know what i really cannot
think of a housewife in recent history
who's had a worse start to a season
especially like a brand new housewife i
think there's like a whole thing about
the second season curse like no matter
how good or whatever your first season
was second season is always rough for a
new housewife i honestly
cannot
remember a housewife who had a war
season so quickly what are we on the
third episode yeah
like and her offline actions are making
it worse right it's not getting better
what is she doing i don't know
i have no idea she would be better off
explaining
even if she believed it or not coming up
with a reason why she found what sutton
said to be problematic right because
then it's like all right at least you're
not lying you're just like i think it's
a bad taste it's a bad take yeah yeah
she would be better off just like
sticking to her guns even if like she
doesn't feel that way you know what i
mean yeah as opposed to digging another
right this route that she's taking to
get herself out of this mess is one of
the worst i think she's doing the exact
same thing and she said look suddenly
sudden and i know what was said and
we've spoken at length about it and she
has apologized to me privately and
publicly so if she apologized publicly
then we know what it was and it was what
she said i see color that we no i don't
see color yeah that we
already know about i can't deal with the
web but you know what she might do she
might spin it
so far that we stop
caring uh keeping up that's an
interesting route to take like fatigue
fatigue is definitely real like you just
go back and forth in drama so much so
many times that the audience like can't
keep up and they just stop caring yeah
that's good but i don't know if if
crystal is experienced enough as a
housewife and like klug enough to know
that that's an option
i think she's just really being who she
is yep and that might naturally be how
this ends for her right fatigue this is
so weird like not at all what i was
expecting to happen this season on
beverly hills no so weird so weird
are you ready for our next story though
i think i am jeffrey epstein's pedophile
island gets a price cut after two months
for sale
it's no surprise that jeffrey up sees
two islands in the caribbean notoriously
referred to as pedophile island or
having a hard time scoring a buyer the
islands known as great saint james and
little st james listed together in march
425 million but now they're hitting the
market separately for 55 million dollars
a piece representing a 12 reduction in
overall ask and combine they're now
going for 110 million dollars yeah um
when you were on maternity leave when we
first like announced that they were on
the market for 125 and me and ben were
like what
are they gonna do and ben actually
thought like a hotel chain should buy it
um and just take over the whole property
and like in a few years like people
would forget and it's not like you're
not gonna go to like a great hotel just
because like years ago something bad
happened would you well they would have
to like raise the whole house and
everything but you know they would get
rid of everything and like literally
build a resort on its own island yeah
like marriott should buy it or something
yeah no that's a good idea like assuming
there's no dead bodies or anything right
you'd have to do a major excavation yeah
or i mean if you're a rich person in the
market for an island you just wait this
out because the price is going to go
down a little bit more but whoever did a
great deal buys it needs to destroy the
house and i think even if it wasn't
previously pedophile island like rich
people don't live in other people's
houses like when you buy a house and
you're like so rich you destroy it and
like make yourself a new one especially
when it's an island but his townhouse in
new york like
it was bought right i mean it's
such an iconic rare
piece piece of real estate like
i think
the fact that it was up for sale was so
rare people didn't care that it was
literally the breeding ground for
grooming and pedophilia right so that
makes sense to me but i think like in
terms of private islands like i think
they're a bunch for sale like i don't
think it's like once in a lifetime
opportunity goes up for sale like if
you're super rich like you can buy your
own island they're all over the virgin
islands oh interesting but this is a
good price
you know and if it keeps going down like
a very uh maybe like a frugal
either a frugal billionaire or someone
who might have not been able to afford
an island right that's an island right
but it's actually so crazy like the
whole island thing when i was in the
british virgin islands we were taking a
boat between islands and like the guy
who the captain was just like pointing
to different islands like the guy who
started google over there richard
branson like it's like a thing like
everyone has their own island it's crazy
that is crazy and then when the place
sells where did the proceeds go
who gets the money i'm sure there are
many lawsuits against his estate
and them liquidating all of their assets
is to pay those like legal fees
people who sued him
i'm sure there's a place for the money
but you're right he didn't have any kids
like if there's anything left over in
jeffrey epstein's estate where does that
go
good question also his manhattan mansion
sold for 51 million dollars in march i
mean and his palm beach home sold for
18.5 million again another piece of real
estate that just doesn't come available
very often the palm beach house has
already been torn down yeah of course
like see that doesn't surprise me
because scandal or not like real estate
is real estate and in new york and palm
beach like you'd be hard-pressed to find
a townhouse on the upper east side
that's literally been standing since
like the 1700s and you'd be hard-pressed
to find an oceanfront beach house
everyone flocked to palm beach during
all the rich people flock to palm beach
during the pandemic there's no real
estate like that's not shocking at all
but like this random island where it's
like also the island was first of all
none of his other houses had names
pedophilia island makes it hard to sell
and that really was like the major major
breeding ground i think the abuse
happened at all of his homes but that
one was like the most notorious and the
plane to the lolita express to the
pedophile island like
it was really the center of the scandal
yeah like even on netflix when you go
watch this documentary filthy rich it's
a picture of the island yeah
okay well
maybe it'll get cheap enough that we
could buy it 110 million i will take it
for 35
what would you pay for it i think we had
this conversation a million dollars yeah
a million dollars
yeah
you never know you never know
times are tough too
yeah are you ready for our next story
only if it's a next story that's brought
to you by
movement
it is in a tiny apartment in southern
california two college dropouts teamed
up to create a watch brand that broke
all the rules with fair prices
unexpected colors and clean original
designs movement grew into one of the
fastest growing watch brands shipping to
over 160 countries across the globe now
movement has expanded into blue light
glasses sleek jewelry and more style
essentials that don't break the bank all
designed out of their california
headquarters and you guys are the first
to know that movement is having a huge
site-wide sale for their father's day
sale their prices are slashed up to 40
off from may 31st to june 17th to make
sure that you can get the perfect gift
for dad from classic dress watches to
adventure watches to summer ready
boating glasses
so quality modern watches for fair price
at movement they're super durable
glasses with uv rated polarized lenses
and timeless styles their premium blue
light glasses will not only make you
look great but they filter 90 of most of
the intense blue light rays from your
digital screens so you can scroll
comfortably and fall asleep easily
father's day is coming up so for your
husband your dad check out movement
watches it's really affordable sleek
elegant jewelry that doesn't break the
bank shop up to forty percent off for
father's day and say big
on the perfect gift for dad join the
movement by going to m v m t dot com
slash toast now and you can enjoy up to
forty percent off that's movement
spelled mvmt.com
toast
great our next story rebel wilson just
came out on instagram by posting a cute
picture with her girlfriend so rebel
wilson took to instagram to post a
picture with her girlfriend ramona aguma
she captioned it saying i thought i was
searching for a disney prince but maybe
what i really needed all this time was a
disney princess the caption is giving
chugi but i'm still happy for her but i
just had to point out like it's like
really like a a britney spears level two
chew galicious a hundred percent and now
you can go back and see like she
actually has been stepping out with her
girlfriend for a while yeah brought her
to the vanity fair oscar's party right
and now she's confirming the romance
this was um shocking
yeah
and also i guess like i and i'm not used
rebel wilson is like reaching a new
level of fame now where like previously
i feel like we knew her strictly
professionally and she was like never
telling us like about her personal life
you know yeah but i think now that she
like seems to be in this like great
place in her life yeah she feels
comfortable opening up she's opened up a
lot about her weight loss and now she
love life sharing a lot over the last
few months in general it was getting to
be like rebels mindless news
i believe we've spoken about this
already um i am getting rebel fatigue
because it's it's giving mindless news
it's giving kelly ripa
so um that doesn't take away from the
fact that i'm happy for her for finding
up until now it had been mindless rebels
mindless news yeah but now this is
mindfulness no this is like something
newsworthy yeah so i'm really happy for
her but i'm glad you pointed out um
she's definitely taken an interesting pr
turn in the last year yeah of just like
selling every feeling she's nothing and
it started out slow because she was like
living in australia and like was slowly
documenting her weight loss on social
media and every time she did it was like
a huge news story and then she's like i
think when she like completed her
fitness journey she started working
again and doing more movies and more
press and like then it got to a place
where it was like it's a lot yeah and
just like sharing you know we talked
about that sorry even though this was
more mindful that like her agents were
saying that she shouldn't lose weight
um
that would like ruin her career
something like that did you watch senior
year her netflix movie no but i saw the
trailer it looks good and i've heard
good things me and ben watch it i didn't
finish it not because it was bad but
like i just can't watch movies like i
find them to be so long um so i watched
the first half and i was enjoying it and
then finished it and really liked it and
i think that you would like it
i think i would too like the way they
encapsulate like being a 17 year old in
like the early 2000s is on point that's
funny it's like really um
maybe it's not early 2000s i think it's
maybe 90s it's like butterfly clips
mandy moore candy driving a punch buggy
like it's really they nail it honestly
okay i will watch it i have i haven't
watched tv aside from homework
in weeks um but i will add it to my
content plate i need to start you know
writing things down i know because i
need to go to the movies and see downton
abbey top gun and elvis and um like i
know i'm never going to do it and that
makes me sad because i do really want to
so badly
you know and they like pete i'm always
reading like instagram quotes and like
inspirational like [ __ ] that's like you
are literally in charge of your own
destiny like you want something make it
happen like i want to see top gun
and i can make it happen but i know that
it will never happen it's like i'm
really not in charge of my destiny it's
like you want to have seen top cut yeah
but you don't want to go see topic right
we should just go and stop talking about
it no i know we need to spend like one
whole day in the theater no we talked
about why we can't do that you can't do
you can't do double headers okay so
we're going to the movies and elvis is
playing
um downton abbey's playing and top guns
playing what are we seeing top gun
top gun because i still want to watch
downton abbey in my home top gun like i
think it's a theatrical experience i
agree and everybody's talking about it
and like we're missing it yeah we really
maybe we'll do it this weekend i think
we should like why not why not
let's look at times totally okay
are you ready for our fifth and final
story oh my god our final our fifth and
final story on the fifth and final day
of the week you guys it doesn't get more
final than that beautiful
it doesn't get more final do you have a
song in your heart oh right i was like
oh right i was like go
she's so scary
i still like balsamic in my throat
it's the um
it's the final story
tastes like
your sister's ass
and that's the magic number
she wants balsamic now you know
you know
have you ever heard the phrase your
sister's ass from you yeah i kind of
want to start incorporating that into
like my everyday jargon you're in charge
of your own destiny i know so i know it
won't happen so did you crawl up your
sister's ass and it smelled like your
sister's ass
what's that from okay i'm glad you
brought it up um when me and ben were in
puerto rico no you i'm glad you asked
when me and ben were in puerto rico a
few years ago we were staying at a hotel
and there was a casino in the hotel so
obviously like every night we went to
the casino and like it started to be
like the same people every night it's
like we started like became like like a
family
and it was these um
it was a bunch of people but the two
people me and ben liked the best until
like the very last night when they said
something hella anti-semitic and i was
like we gotta go um but up until then it
was all fun their names were mike and
connie and they were like classic i
think he was like a full-time bookie she
was a cocktail waitress they were like
so iconic jersey and every time he lost
a hand he would he would literally slime
his fist on the table like oh you're
sisters ass so me and ben started saying
it a lot cute i'm glad you guys took
that trip to puerto rico because it's
really provided you a lot of content
over the years what else you just like
to talk about mike and connie a lot i
literally would take a bullet for them
and i'm actually almost 100 sure i have
one of their phone numbers just give me
a second should you call them and say
your sister's ass but it was funny
because like we only hung out at night
and then like the crew started to get
like tight like there was this other
couple this bald guy who was really hot
and like his girlfriend was really hot
and they were like we're gonna go to
this like special beach cave tomorrow
like do you guys want to come like when
we were drunk we were like yeah sure
when i woke up i'm like
you want me to be seen with these people
in the light of day
there's literally no way
all right let me check connie
connie with the wine no
mike
connie is i.e
you know i also checked with y no i
guess i don't have their number ben
probably does i'm sure ben gets lunch
with him once a month 100
okay i'm ready for the fifth final okay
khloe kardashian confirms that kim is in
love with pete davidson chloe adorably
responded to a tweet about how in love
kim is with boyfriend pete davidson
while watching watching thursday's
episode of the kardashians when a
twitter user wrote kimberly is in love
lmao it's so cute chloe replied isn't it
she is in love chloe was making a lot of
waves on her twitter she also liked to
tweet that was like [ __ ] truths and
thompson good yeah good it's about time
she comes back out swinging you know
yeah she's been far too kind and i get
it like a father of two i get it and
maybe it's because i don't have kids but
like how about it no no when is tristan
gonna be like it's mother of true and
maybe i should respect this one right no
it's like he doesn't respect the
familial bond between them why the [ __ ]
should chloe why should familial respect
only flow in one direction 100
but back to kim and pete like super
happy for them um they're in love they
were in love on last night's episode
also she's just smitten as a kitten
we're gonna get into the recap but
before we do like
did you feel like when she was talking
about like pete and stuff like did you
like cringe a little bit which part when
she was in the kitchen with courtney and
chloe just like talking about like i
just screamed ago no
when she was in the kitchen was two
episodes ago she was talking about
pimple cream
oh okay then maybe no then i'm talking
about something else like she was like
he asked me to go get ice cream i was
like so horny oh yes cringe cringe yeah
yeah like my shoulders like physically
concave she said that in the
confessional yeah just trying to talk
about like how they just do like small
things and just living life with him and
being normal is like what turns her on
but yeah it was a weird way to say it it
was just like her saying recently that
she would eat duty if it made her
younger
nobody asked yeah i guess that's like
pete rubbing off on her like because
he's like kooky and crazy and funny and
like yeah i'm not liking it on kim it's
like it's cringe yeah it's just a lot
yeah no it's a lot it's just like these
are extreme statements that nobody asked
you to make um okay so let's dive into
the tv recap which is brought to you by
the breeze luminess so
you've got to check out luminess and
their new breeze cordless airbrush
makeup if you don't have a lot of time
to get ready in the morning like we
don't um you're always looking for a way
to put on makeup faster so the breeze is
a completely touchless way to put on
foundation it's so fast and easy to use
there's no sponges brushes or fingers
that you need to keep clean with
luminesce you get three times more
coverage and you use ten times less
makeup it's designed to work with all
skin types skin tones and their water
based foundation quickly and easily
covers fine lines wrinkles it conceals
imperfections and it applies flawlessly
in seconds so they're available in 18
shades the luminous foundation they've
got a color for every skin type and they
will replace your shade for free if it
doesn't match their product is cruelty
free it's made in the usa it has an 18
hour wear so there's no need to reapply
your makeup in the middle of the day the
part that i love about it is that the
cordless airbrush system is actually
really small you would think it's like
this big it's actually really small you
can throw it in your purse really easy
to travel with um and i love the idea of
not touching on my makeup because like
who has time for that
if you've been looking forever for a
makeup that doesn't look heavy or cakey
on your face you will finally find it
with luminess breeze airbrush just like
we did whether you're heading back to
the office updating your beauty routine
or just looking for a better faster way
to put on your foundation we've got good
news right now if you go to
breezetoday.com
toast
and put in promo code toast you'll
receive 50 off their airbrush makeup
system plus free shipping and because
you're a listener there's a free
eyeliner valued at over twenty dollars
included just for you so it's fifty
percent off plus free shipping when you
go to breezetoday.com
toast and put in promo code toast don't
forget you get 30 days to try out the
luminess breeze and if you don't love it
send it back for a full refund
awesome okay the kardashians episode
nine let's go sister by sister okay
courtney you know i actually thought it
was really interesting that a story line
was the show it was like very meta
breaking the fourth wall she's mad that
like when she saw the edited episode of
the engagement there was a whole
storyline about scott because in real
life she was like it was literally a
five second conversation the whole night
wasn't about it and literally nobody was
talking about it and i kind of do
understand her frustration yeah no she's
totally on point it's just like as a
viewer i like care about scott and i
worry about like his integration into
the family and i want him to be at
everything so yeah that's what we're all
thinking but if i'm courtney you people
are crazy yeah i'm in the happiest place
in my life i'm living a fairy tale what
else is there to talk about this scott
hasn't been together for five years and
mistreated me for ten years and then for
five years still couldn't be the man
that i needed him to be and now and not
only is she in a fairytale relationship
like she's with travis barker another
interesting human being like another
star she's dating some nobody that we
don't care to know about like totally
they're blending families like they've
got so much going on they're doing their
voodoo stuff yeah like
it's interesting stuff no she's totally
justified yeah even though as a viewer
like i am wondering where does scott fit
into all of this right but if i'm her
i'm just like you people are crazy and
i'm offended but do you feel like they
like
moved forward like a bunch of time
since the engagement
yeah because if she's already seen the
episodes edited it got confusing because
it feels like they fast forward jumped
like kylie's about to give birth right
but what about thanksgiving and
christmas right so i was really confused
and then kim shot s.i she was doing that
in january
and they were talking and that was also
the same time where like kanye was out
with julia foxx so when they were
talking about you know she wants the
drama like she's talking about that
right the last time we saw them it was
the beginning of november right so i'm
actually i like that they're talking
about things like we just saw kim came
out on sports illustrated so now we get
to see the photo shoot like i like that
the time has kind of crunched a little
bit but i did feel like they took a huge
chunk out and maybe it was because of
astroworld yes
maybe i think maybe they like probably
stopped filming for a while for the
holidays and took a break but like can
you let us know it was confusing because
i'm like you got engaged like three
episodes ago how are you already seeing
the final cut no what was confusing to
me was i thought it was november and
then they're like kylie's about to give
birth but she gave birth in february
right but then kim was doing si and that
was in january so it was obviously like
these were the last weeks of january
confusing
yes so that was courtney and then i
think there was something else with
corny oh benny drama
i have to say i enjoyed that immensely
first of all i loved the video when it
came out of benny at courtney's house i
think benny is so funny and talented and
he was great on the show like i loved it
no he was great on the show and he was
also great in courtney's presence like i
feel like when you get famous for doing
spoofs or just being a fan of someone
like
they could be all into like van mode but
he was businessman comedian mode like
what are we doing and how are we doing
it he killed it and he's so funny like
yeah i
i loved it yeah um and then kim went to
the dominican republic which just looks
like the worst trip of all time like
strep throat in a pool no thank you but
she did look really beautiful in si and
two things one i loved seeing mj day
like that was so iconic yeah and two
i guess i didn't really realize like how
different kim looks now than she did
even in january like before the met gala
because of her weight loss yeah yeah
everyone was like she lost so much
weight on my she literally looks the
same she doesn't look the same now
because when she was in the bikini and
then we've been seeing her like looking
she looks she really did lose a lot of
weight i didn't notice yeah because i
think it like
i don't know i just didn't notice it
yeah no the si stuff was really
interesting and then also doing skims
and it's just a lot uh also
it's crazy how she's so close with
natalie and olivia i know but also we
don't like see the ins and outs of their
friendship to like understand why
they're so close and how they're so
close based on the show like nat and
olivia are mute like they literally
don't talk great but like on lags and on
their own show they have really big
personalities and i'm sure they do and
but like
they just it felt like they were like
hired to just ask a question that came
good answer so we could have this scene
no and they're like it's so cute yeah i
was like say something
literally speak
no but like those are her two best
friends she took them to the dr yeah
i was confused
show us like why you're all best friends
we also finally found out what it was
that pete had delivered to the plane it
was dibs ice cream why was that a
cliffhanger it was such a letdown and
honestly like i do love dibs like give
me a dip i'll consume the entire pack
but like who cares
it's just like her way of showing us how
sweet it's her way of showing us their
relationship without showing us the
relationship you know but eventually she
will show us the relationship especially
because
they're so serious yeah
it's just shocking like is he living
with her now i don't know because as
reported earlier on the morning toast
even though we didn't talk about it
pete was out walking around with steam
at walmart i still don't care about that
but i have to imagine like he doesn't
come to a lane stay at a hotel no and
he's not flying back once a week anymore
for snl right and he wasn't even barely
doing it at that so right he definitely
lives in l.a
i'm sure he has his own place that he
never goes to
you know i don't think he has a place in
my life i do because kim is always doing
stuff like busy busy he's not gonna like
chill in her house with her maybe her
guest house
i think he has his own place but like
when kim is home he's there and when
kim's not there he's at his own place
because he's like friends and stuff he
likes to smoke weed he's not gonna smoke
weed with the kids maybe he stays at a
friend's place i don't think he has his
own place
i don't know
we need to know more we'll find out in a
year on the kardashians this is a case
for the fbi it is a case for the fbi and
then my favorite storyline of the
episode was the good american same the
open casting open casting one the this
show has just become a large commercial
for all of their brands like the amount
of good american
promo that we got beyond like the
interesting part that i did enjoy it was
like explaining what good american is
showing all the clothes it's just a
commercial the fact that they literally
will not sell into a store that doesn't
buy the full size range is the most
iconic thing i've ever heard yeah no but
like and they won't put them all you
have to be on the same floor you don't
get bigger sizes on a different floor i
feel like last week it was skims it's a
commercial for their brands and it never
it doesn't bother me and it never has
bothered me but i'm really starting to
notice it now where it's like i feel
like i'm watching
a paid infomercial yeah even though the
zooms where she was like telling people
they weren't if you didn't have a tear
in your eye i don't want to talk to you
crying like it was so sweet and i just
like the what i've gathered from this
show is many things but i think my
biggest takeaway from this new show
where we i feel like we're really
getting to know the girls personalities
on a different level is like chloe is
like a once in a lifetime kind of like
soul yeah i think she's literally so
kind i've never seen someone just like
rally and back up her friends more and
it's also someone who's been through a
lot like and she doesn't like walk
around woe is me and she's just like
like my takeaway and even at simon's
wedding when i was like in their
presence my takeaway there was like clo
if i had to hang out with one of them
i'd want to hang out with chloe she was
literally there all night drinking
taking shots dancing with the gays like
it was so iconic last person on the
dance floor i just feel like
the show has done wonders for all of
them but i feel like it really showed us
who chloe is yeah and i love what i'm
seeing but it also makes all of these
scandals these tristan stuff
even more because she deserves love and
just like a strong partner companion so
much and she's clearly just the type of
person because we're all like oh my gosh
she got back to together with tristan
again she's clearly just this girl who's
like hopeless like a hopeless romantic
really has like belief and trust in
people not even that i don't blame her
for getting back with tristan like he
was so far up her ass and the whole
family and begging her and begging her
and i'm gonna be different and like at a
certain point like okay shut up we'll
get back together like you are the
father of my child this is i at one
point was attracted to you and liked you
it would be easiest if we got back
together so i don't think it's because
she like can't quit him i think it's
because like he's so [ __ ] annoying no
and like for him to be so [ __ ]
annoying while still [ __ ] around is
literal mental illness psychopath
diabolical lock him up unwelcome
institution because this man is
unwell you're so right like 100
so i don't i think now like it just she
kept like believing that he would change
because he went to such lengths to show
her that we would even for all of us i
was fine with them getting back together
you sat down with chris like he really
you're right went to such extremes just
to do it all again why so weird
and like i don't fault her for getting
back together with him when kim was
putting it all together like
he had sex with her on her 30th birthday
chloe threw him his 30th birthday party
like that
then it also made me think is there a
big age difference between chloe and
tristan chloe's still in her 30s but
she's in her high 30s yes and he just
turned 30 yeah and so he's clearly
extremely immature yeah but when he was
when they were first getting together
he's probably like 27 26 that's is kind
of young not to make any excuse no i
mean excuse me i'm 27 i've been married
for five years right but like to be a 26
year old athlete like no it's a lot in
the prime of your career
you're going to [ __ ] around so don't
have a baby and get into a relationship
with someone it's extreme and you keep
asking them to take you back and take
you seriously when you're not a serious
person yeah
you're actually like a big fat liar the
morning of which was just like crazy to
see how it all unraveled of course like
kim knew first and then like the sister
conference call like every sister just
kept calling and merging calling
emerging that was just like it's nice to
see how these things go down not that i
was happy that it went down obviously um
and of course they gave us nothing and
they cut to commercial or whatever like
next week so we really don't know what
chloe's
reaction is i don't think she knew
anything and i think she is gonna be
shook
yeah
and i think like this time around it
probably hurts so much more because it's
literally full me once shame on you fool
me twice shame on me this is for me
three times i know this is for me a
third time yeah
it's
moronic she just deserves like someone
who gives her even one percent of what
she gives other people that would be
yeah
diana and said zilch yeah negative
actually because they actually detract
yeah it's not like kevin fetterline who
just sits on the couch and lives off the
land right
that would be yeah that would be better
it better but someone who someone like
chloe really just barrios someone like
chloe deserves like a once in a lifetime
love of course that's what courtney and
travis have and what kim and pete have
yeah like she really and you know what
her time will come and she'll look back
on all this be like i had to go through
that to get to this but in this moment
like you just feel sadness for her for
sure and like just like court i mean
courtney never really dated that many
people but just like kim did where she's
now like with someone that she probably
never thought that she would be with
pete like chloe needs to
stop dating athletes
yep and
start dating accountants no and i think
like the sisters like for a while were
really into athletes and now they're
moving on to like musicians and like
comedians like different and maybe
chloe because chloe's also into athletes
like maybe she'll now
go to you know maybe skip the basketball
game and go to
a concert go to like uh you know
a business conference at the javits
center the one
what's the ces yeah like go to a trade
show a trade show because she's looking
for love in all the wrong places yeah or
maybe she'll go to like a comedy
festival yeah and look at all the
headlines notoriously
nefarious yeah
and i just want real
real love for chloe
nobody deserves it more
and it was a really sad episode yeah but
it was good honestly the way i watched
the episode it was like i had to pause
so many times because i was i was
watching it like all day it felt like
the longest episode ever but like in a
really good way i was like this episode
never ends and like no one it was really
just the three older sisters right
kendall wasn't in it kendall and chloe
went baby shopping boring so kendall
wasn't in it try to catch me here who's
chris chris caccio pepe
pepe she's not married to corey do you
see corey dancing solo on the plane
in an episode no on his instagram yes i
did
king king and i know that there was like
a few months ago like a major like
like allegation about cory and cheating
what yeah like there was like a video of
him in a club with a girl um and like i
like how we all just breeze past it and
it's not gonna work for me no i'm i'm
gonna breeze past it too yeah it was a
quarry impersonator or it was from 10
years ago yeah it can't be the cory that
i know and love that does not work for
me it doesn't sit well it doesn't sit
right it's not right and him and chris
are together in capri right now so
they're good even though why wasn't he
at the wedding
he must have had covert that could only
be the reason that's what people said
but he was also like out and about like
getting coffee so that's not gonna work
not wearing a mask that's not gonna work
for me either no i know
don't even put this in my head i know
then i'm like done then i'm gonna
actually just sell my whole ship
enterprise i'm gonna get out of the
business of shipbuilding yeah because i
can't take any more destruction no
they're like your first big investment
they're they're one of my biggest ships
yeah i'm obsessed no i think they're
they're good but like there was
something
um so that was the kardashians recap
that is our show anything else you want
to say to everyone before we sign off
for the week no have an amazing weekend
make sure to acknowledge the space that
you're in meditate take the time take
stock
hug a strict
and enjoy your weekend you guys because
it'll be monday before you know it and
it'll be back on the hamster wheel thank
you guys so much for listening to the
morning toast monday morning show where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as podcasts
anywhere podcasts can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
heart radio cast box all the places so
if you listen to podcasts find this
morning just leave a five-star review
about how beautiful standing and smart
we are having an amazing weekend we love
you guys and we'll see you on monday bye
you